do you remember meeting this
you know uh
jeffrey or
or gillian
no i never met them but they're also
very much like this sort of upper east
side crowd um i did meet harvey
weinstein once that made me have all
kinds of interesting thoughts later
at the restaurant or elsewhere no it was
weird it was out on the street
and we had this really strange
interaction
and
knowing what i know now it was eerie and
and also like had he contacted me after
that
and made it seem like he could have done
something for me like would i have been
you know say he said oh i'm gonna
finance your whole expansion or
something and like come to my you know
come meet me at this hotel and then i go
to that hotel and then he's like come up
to the room and then i would have been
like uh
and you're wondering whether you would
have done it
yes and sadly i think i would have and
so i felt a lot of
compassion for
um
those who
you know
didn't
yell at him and leave or didn't storm
out
and because i think
what happens in those situations
is um
you know there's all kinds of
uncertainty in the moment and you sort
of freeze and then you'll if
i'm probably one of those people that
would
sit there and somehow in the moment
without clarity
just instinctively feel like somehow i
must have done something wrong and it's
my fault and and like i led him on and
or just being afraid and then and then
you don't know how to deal with it and
so you freeze
um
so i think that
you know if you're somebody that maybe
was raised differently or you have a lot
of self-confidence or
um you might have
reacted differently and kind of
pushed them away and stormed out
um
but
i am probably not one of those people
but i did not ever meet jeffrey epstein
but he seems very straightforwardly um
you know just a classic the way he was
able to charm people the way he
could step into these roles um
you know i think he was teaching at
dalton and then
just kind of the way he would get
himself into the
the academic crowd within harvard and i
think also mit right he sort of
so he's playing a role but he's doing it
so well that he fools all these people
and what and the things that people
would
in hindsight say about him
are just the same things that people say
about it's like you hear the same things
over and over again you hear the same
thing said about those people who were
taken in by elizabeth holmes is that
they were like
it was as if he was under a spell it was
as if i was under a spell
is something you hear a lot
and so it's like they have this
powerful charm that's almost over it's
overwhelming in that they overwhelm your
better judgment or they overwhelm your
like normal
otherwise normally functioning capacity
for
rational thought and they sort of
overwhelm that with their charm so
you know when you look at i think it was
like james mattis invested a bunch of
money with elizabeth holmes and
all these people were involved with her
and nobody really did their due
diligence where they just sort of
trusted her
and jeffrey epstein
i think it's still unclear where he got
all of his money
but the guy
wexner
who had you know
an enormous amount of money and somehow
very quickly turned over management of
it to jeffrey epstein and so people
wonder like why would he do that that's
insane
and and and then other people have
commented about that relationship like
it was as if he was under jeffrey's
spell you know observers would say i
couldn't understand it it was as if he
was under his spell and so somebody
observing
me and mr fox could have possibly said
the same thing about me but it's a bit
different because it wasn't all charm i
think um epstein used his charm and then
was probably very very very crafty and
getting um another thing that people
like him do and cults do also is to get
um
is to get you somehow compromised
because then they've got you
so i think
some kind of
usually sex related
yeah and with epstein certainly you know
he was known to have cameras everywhere
and so if he got any of these people on
camera doing something compromising and
on all very powerful people
then he's got them
um and i think he was also very smart to
do that to target people of both parties
so that politically
that he was able to maintain his power
like no matter
like
nobody wanted him to be totally exposed
because then
people
a lot of people would be exposed um by
the way that part you know
that's all kind of
conspiracy right
right we don't know that
i
so a lot of people believe that and
you know i tend to kind of naturally
believe that because that makes sense
but it's also possible that
straight up with charisma
i mean he did record people and there
were recordings so
i listened to an interview with a woman
who i mean was a girl back then maybe
she was 15 or 16 back then
um
and subsequently
years later
was able to see some of the video of
um i mean i think that's a verifiable
thing that there were video cameras all
over his house
the degree to which it was used
right we don't know that
and um
to the degree of how many people were
involved and so on there's all kinds of
conspiracies around the man
you